luis
you suggested an interesting idea
imagine
if most papers had a backstory section
the same way that they have an abstract
so
knowing more about how the authors ended
up working on a paper can be extremely
insightful
and then you went on to give a backstory
for the feynman qed paper
this is all in a tweet by the way we're
doing tweet analysis today
how much of the human backstory do you
think is important in understanding
the idea itself that's presented in the
paper or in general
i think this gives way more context to
the work of
of scientists i think people a lot of
people have this
almost kind of romantic misconception
that
the way a lot of scientists work is
almost as the sum
of eureka moments where all of a sudden
they sit down and start writing
two papers in a row and the papers are
usually isolated
and when you actually look at it it's
the papers are you know
chapters of a way more complex uh story
and the definement qed paper is a good
example so feynman was actually going
through a pretty dark
phase before writing that paper it was
he lost
enthusiasm with physics and doing
physics problems
and there was one time when he was in
the cafeteria of cornell
and he saw a guy that was throwing
flights in the air
and he noticed that there was when the
plate was in the air there were two
movements there
the plate was wobbling but he also
noticed that the the cornell symbol was
rotating and he was able to figure out
the equations of motions
uh the equations of motions of those uh
plates
and that uh led him to kind of think a
little bit about
uh electron orbits in relativity which
led to
the paper of um about quantum
electrodynamics so that kind of
reignited
his interest in physics and and and
ended up publishing the paper that led
to the
his nobel prize basically and i think
it's it's
there are a lot of really interesting
backstories about papers that readers
never get to know friends we did a
couple of months ago
um an ama around
a paper a pretty famous paper the gans
paper with ian goodfellow
and so we did an ama where everyone was
could ask questions about the paper and
ian was
responding to those questions you also
he was also telling the story of how he
got the idea for that paper in a bar
so there was also an interesting and a
back story
i also read a book by cedric valani
uh these cedric velani is this
mathematician the fields medalist
and in his book he tries to explain how
he got from like
a phd student to the fields metal and he
tries to be as descriptive as possible
every single step how we got to the
fields metal
and it's interesting also to see just
the amount of random interactions and
discussions with other researchers
sometimes over coffee
and how it led to like fundamental
breakthroughs and some of his most
important papers so
i think it's super interesting to have
that context of of the backstory
well the ian goodfellow story is kind of
interesting and perhaps that's true for
feinman as well i don't know if it's
romanticizing the thing but
it seems like just a few little insights
and a little bit of work
does most of the leap required do you
have a sense that for a lot of the stuff
you've looked at
just looking back through history uh it
wasn't necessarily the grind of like
andrew wiles or the females last theorem
for example
it was more like a a brilliant moment of
insight
in fact ian goodfellow has a kind of
sadness to him almost
in that at that time in machine learning
like at that time especially in uh for
gans
you could code something up really
quickly on a single machine
and almost do the invention go from idea
to uh experimental validation in like a
single night
a single person could do it and now
there's kind of a sadness that a lot of
the breakthroughs you might have in
machine learning
kind of require large scale experiments
so it was almost like the early days
so i wonder how many low-hanging fruit
there are
in science and mathematics and even
engineering where it's like
you could do that little experiment
quickly like you have an insight and a
bar
why is it always a bar but you have an
insight at a bar and then
just implement and the world changes
it's it's a good point i think it also
depends a lot on the maturity of the
field
when you look at a field like
mathematics like it's a pretty
mature field uh feels like machine
learning
it's it's growing pretty fast and
it's actually pretty pretty interesting
i i looked up like the number of
new papers on archive with the keyword
machine learning
and like 50 of those papers have been
published
on in the last 12 months so you can see
just the same
zero five zero fifty percent so you can
see the the
the magnitude of growth in that field
and so i think
like as fields mature like those types
of of moments
i think naturally uh are less frequent
um it's just a consequence of that
the other point that is interesting
about the backstory is that it can
really make it
more memorable in a way and and by
making it more memorable it's
it kind of sediments the knowledge more
in your mind i remember
also reading the sort of the backstory
to
to dijkstra's shortest path algorithm
right where where
he he came up with it uh essentially
while he was
sitting down at a at a coffee shop in
amsterdam
and he and he came up with that
algorithm over 20 minutes
and one interesting aspect is that he
didn't have any pen or paper
at the time and so he had to do it all
in his mind and so there's only so much
complexity that you can handle if you're
just thinking about it in your mind
and that like when you think about the
simplicity of dijkstra's
shortest path finding algorithm it's you
know
knowing that backstory helps sediment
that algorithm in your mind
so that you don't forget about it as
easily it might be from you that i
saw a meme about texture
it's like he's trying to solve it he
comes up with some kind of random path
and then it's like my parents aren't
home and then he does
uh he figures out the algorithm for the
shortest path
all right through words to convey memes
but that's hilarious
i don't know if it's in post that we
construct stories that romanticize it
apparently with newton there was no
apple especially when you're working on
problems that have a physical
manifestation
or a visual manifestation it feels like
the world
could be an inspiration to you so it
doesn't have to be completely
in um on paper like you could be sitting
at a bar
and all of a sudden see something and a
pattern will
will spark another pattern and you can
visualize it
and rethink a problem in a particular
way
of course you can also load the math
that you have on paper and always carry
that with you so when you show up to the
bar some little inspiration could be the
thing that changes it is there any other
people
almost on the human side whether it's
physics with feynman
derock einstein or computer science
touring anybody
else any backstories that you remember
that jump out
because i'm also referring to not
necessarily these stories where
something magical happens
but these are personalities they have
big egos
some of them are super friendly some of
them are like self-obsessed
some of them have anger issues some of
them how do i
describe feynman but he appears to uh
have a appreciation of the beautiful in
all its forms
it has a wit and a cleverness and a
humor about him so
does that come into play in terms of the
construction of the science
well i think you brought up newton
newton is a it's a good example also to
think about his backstory because
you know there's a certain backstory of
newton that people always
talk about but then there's a whole
another aspect of him
that is also a big part of the person
that he was but you know he was really
into alchemy
right and that he spent a lot of time uh
thinking about that and writing about it
and he took it very seriously he was
really into bible
interpretation trying to predict things
based on the bible
and so there's also a whole backstory
then and of course you need to look at
it in the context
that uh and the time that when when
newton lived
um but a but it adds to his personality
and it's important to also understand
those aspects then maybe
you know uh i'm not people people are
not as proud to teach to little kids
but it's important it was part of who he
was and and maybe without those he
who knows what he would have done
otherwise so
well the the cool thing about alchemy i
don't i don't know how it was viewed at
the time
but it almost like to me symbolizes
dreaming of the impossible like most of
the breakthrough ideas
kind of seem impossible until they're
actually done it's like achieving human
flight
it's not completely obvious to me that
alchemy is impossible
or like putting myself in the mindset of
the time
uh and perhaps even still every
everything that
uh you know some of the most incredible
breakthroughs
are would seem impossible and
i wonder the value of
believing almost like focusing and
dreaming of the
impossible such that it is actually is
possible in your mind and that in itself
manifests
whether the accomplishing that goal or
making progress in some unexpected
direction so alchemy almost symbolizes
that
for me i distinctly remember having the
same thought of thinking you know when i
learned about atoms and
that they have protons and electrons i
was like okay to make gold you just take
whatever has an
atomic weight below it and then shove
another proton in there and then you
have a bunch of gold
so like why don't people do that it
seemed like conceptually is like you
know this sounds feasible
you might be able to do it and you can
actually it's just very very expensive
yeah yeah exactly exactly so in a sense
we do have alchemy
and maybe even back then it wasn't as
crazy that he was so into it
but people just don't like to talk about
that as much yeah but newton in general
is a very interesting fellow
anybody else come to mind in terms of
people that inspire you there's the
people that you just
uh are happy that they have once or
still exist on this earth
i think i mean freeman dyson for me
yeah freeman dyson was was i've had a
chance to actually
exchange a couple of emails with him he
was probably one of the most humble
scientists that i've ever met and that
had a a big impact
on me we were trying we're actually
trying to convince him to
annotate a paper on fermat's library
and i sent him an email asking him um
if you could annotate a paper and his
response was something like
i have very limited knowledge i just
know a couple of things about
certain fields i'm not sure if i'm
qualified to do that
that was his first response and and this
was
someone that should have won an opera
fry's and worked on a bunch of different
fields
um did some really really great work
and then just the interactions that i
had with him every time i asked him
a couple of questions about his papers
and uh
he always responded saying i'm not here
to answer your questions i
i just want to open it more questions um
and uh so that had a big impact on me it
was like just
an example of an extremely humble yet
accomplished scientist and feynman was
also
a big big inspiration in the sense that
he was able to be
you know again extremely talented and
and uh scientist but at the same time
socially
he was able to to he was also really
smart from a social perspective
and he was able to interact with people
it was also
a really good teacher and was also to
did a
awesome work in terms of um explaining
physics to to the masses and motivating
and getting people interested in physics
and that for me was was also a big
inspiration
yeah i like the childlike curiosity of
some of those folks like you mentioned
freeman
i have uh daniel kahneman i got a chance
to meet and interact with
some some of these truly special
scientists
what makes them special is that even in
uh older age
they're still like there's still that
fire of childlike curiosity that burns
and uh some of that is like not taking
yourself so seriously that you think
you've figured it all out
but almost like thinking that you don't
know much of it
and that's like step one in having a
great
conversation or collaboration or
exploring a scientific question it's
cool how
the very thing that probably earned
people the nobel prize
or or work that's seminal in some way
it is the very thing that still burns
even after
uh they've won the prize it's cool to
see and they're rare humans
it seems
you